[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno yo soy de coelemu como mencionaron
anteriormente pero esto no siempre fue
así yo cuando estaba chico vivía en la
gran ciudad que gran ciudad chillán
yo cuando estaba chico consideraba que
chillán era mi centro del mundo porque
era lo más grande que yo conocía no
salía para otras partes y si salía a
otras partes era solamente a ver a mi
abuelita con mi familia a donde íbamos a
ver a mi abuelita a coelemu donde yo
actualmente yo de primera decía no no
quiero ir qué flojera ir a ver la fom y
más adelante cuando fui creciendo me di
cuenta que el hecho de ir a verla ya no
solamente incluía ir a verla a ella sino
que también llegará con él en y llegará
con el lemon que influía ver eso
a mí me encanta la naturaleza
y bueno cuando yo estaba chico cuando
llegamos algo de bueno nos cambiamos de
casa de león
yo viví bueno actualmente vivo donde
vivía mi habilidad
y yo cuando fui comencé bueno fui
creciendo y comenzar me cuenta de qué
lo que había al lado de mi casa que es
el puente que el cual es un patrimonio y
entonces yo puedo decir que vivo al lado
un patrimonio que me ha hecho esto darme
cuenta de que todos los días pasa gente
pero no no gente con mis mismos
intereses en cuidarlo sino que gente que
como se ve en la foto va a tomar se va a
drogar y quizá hay cosas más
pero hoy no venimos hablando de eso
volviendo al tema yo cuando llegué a
coelemu
inscrip bueno me matricularon en un
colegio en el cual tú no era nada si no
tenías buenas notas y no tenías plata
eso
en parte fue
no muy bueno para mí yo estuve de
tercero cuarto quinto sexto y séptimo
básico con buenas notas pero esas buenas
notas ocultaban algo a mí me hacían
bullying en el colegio
entonces yo cuando llegaba del colegio
iba al puente
porque porque era mi lugar de liberación
entonces comencé a darme cuenta a medida
de que iba creciendo de que mi centro
del mundo había cambiado ya no era
chillán ahora era el puente donde yo
podía ir a relajarme
y bueno yo como comentaron anteriormente
también yo dibujo
y eso fue mi vía de escape por así
decirlo a varias cosas de lo que me pasó
en la vida
por ejemplo el bullying
y bueno
yo delante estaba diciendo que llegué
hasta séptimo básico con buenas notas
octavo
fue quizá cuando más sufrí el efecto de
eso del bullying y medio depresión una
depresión cuática
en primero medio yo llegue
y mis notas eran horribles que pasó
repetir de curso quizá para algunos sea
un problema o una falla un impedimento
para mí no para mí fue una oportunidad
poder ampliar mis horizontes cambiar mis
aires cambiarme de colegio a donde me
cambié a un liceo liceo domingo ortiz de
rosas donde estudió actualmente
qué ocurre que en este ligero yo los
primeros días estuve solo no conocía a
nadie y si es que quería conocer a
alguien me decían no no te acerque a él
el culito porque venía del colegio
particular
qué pasó comencé a conocer gente que nos
interesados por las mismas cosas los
cuales eran cuidar la naturaleza el
medio ambiente y el patrimonio
ya hicimos un grupito de personas
se interesaban por lo mismo y bueno
primero comenzamos estábamos en los
recreos decíamos a xavi ya ti te gusta
esto te gusta cuidar la naturaleza te
gusta el medio ambiente te gusta el
patrimonio si ya tenemos cosas en común
haga un amigo ya dale luego de esto
comenzamos a pasar más tiempo
y vamos después de clases al patrimonio
que es el puente
pero no ahí vamos a hacer lo que los
otros hacían tomar drogarse
nosotros íbamos con intenciones de poder
respirar un aire limpio tener un momento
de relajación
algunos también como yo y vamos a
dibujar
nosotros buscamos en algún momento una
manera de rescatar esto la grandeza que
tenía antes el puente y no solamente el
puente sino que varios patrimonios que
hay en coelemu y en el valle del itata
que se han ido perdiendo y nosotros
de esta manera empezamos a cuestionarnos
de que podemos hacerlo podemos hacer un
vídeo no igual como que no va mucho con
el tema podemos hacer un libro si es una
buena idea pero igual como que en medio
complicado pero ahora un libro con
ilustraciones ya quedan algunos nos
gusta dibujar lo de goles o claro
hicimos una jornada de ilustración con
varios alumnos del liceo
qué le gusta dios
y creamos nuestro libro que actualmente
se divide en tres formatos un formato el
cual va dirigido a un público
juvenil/adulto
también trae las ilustraciones y reseñas
hechas por los alumnos de el liceo donde
yo estudio
que también va dirigido a quienes van al
valle del itata a conocer porque va a
tener una guía turística también nuestro
segundo formato el cual es un material
didáctico que nosotros planeamos que
vaya dirigido a un público de niños de 4
a 12 años para que puedan usarlo dentro
del aula de clases con sus docentes y
también nuestro tercer libro
qué es un libro inclusivo inclusivo de
qué manera se preguntarán algunos
porque dentro de nuestro territorio hay
inmigrantes haitianos hay nativos
mapuches y hay gente no videntes por lo
cual este libro nosotros lo traducimos
al mapudungún al braille y al creo
bueno
este libro no habría sido posible de no
hacer por la agrupación a la que yo
pertenezco que me integraron que son los
ecos amigos
los amigos son el grupo de personas que
se interesaron todos por un bien común
el cual en la naturaleza
estamos todos unidos por eso
y la naturaleza una persona de qué
manera me di cuenta yo que la agrupación
al comienzo hubo quizás unos percances
pero esos percances se solucionaron por
qué
no estaban dentro de la agrupación por
otra persona sino que estaban por ellos
y por la naturaleza
entonces eso se solucionó más adelante
con la agrupación comenzamos a hacer
muchas cosas dentro del liceo
no sé si alguno conoce al grupo los
jaivas
bueno nosotros llamamos a dos
integrantes de ese grupo a nuestro liceo
también que es nuestro más reciente
proyecto el cual es un mural de arcilla
y nosotros lo hicimos en un conjunto de
una agrupación de no sé si alguien
conoce que es un mural de arcilla
qué podría decir sobre un mural darse
que tarjeta de alicante
pero lo más importante es que representa
a los oficios campesinos que hay dentro
del valle del itata
y qué más podría decir la naturaleza una
persona te lo dije anteriormente
pero les quiero preguntar a ustedes
ustedes viajan
ustedes cuando viajan se dan cuenta de
lo bonito del lugar al que van
y cuántos de ustedes han hecho el
ejercicio de desconectarse cuando viajan
yo cuando viajo hago eso guardo el
celular respiro me pongo a dibujar y si
no me quedo quieto pero sin la
tecnología
concluyendo esto la naturaleza una
personas y si alguno duda de eso es
quizá porque no ha levantado la cabeza y
la vista del celular muchas gracias
[Aplausos]